the 2022 midterms are approaching and a
new book is out now aiming to debunk
some of the false claims made about the
2020 election the timing is good because
it comes as a CBS News poll finds a
majority of Americans believe that for
future Generations the U.S will be less
of a democracy than it is right now
that's a majority belief this is fueled
in part of course by the false claims of
former president Trump that the election
was stolen from him in 2020. the book is
called the big truth upholding democracy
in the age of the big lie and it argues
the 2020 election was actually a Triumph
of democracy it says election denial now
puts our nation at risk for in fact a
civil war it's co-written by Major
Garrett CBS news's Chief Washington
correspondent and David Becker executive
director and founder of the center for
election Innovation and research uh
gentlemen good morning to both of you uh
the book is co-written but I hear each
of your voices at different times and I
think that there's a very interesting
contrast at the center of this book on
the one hand you have what was a
tremendous accomplishment the 2020
election one of the smoothest most
successful of all time I hear your voice
in that and yet we have this astounding
denial of it that imperils us and as you
put it or I hear both of you say
Civil War is stalking us and we have
those are the stakes and that's the
contradiction let's take them in part
starting with you David how was the 2020
election one of the most successful in
modern American history well if you look
at all the objective facts that we know
from 2020 we had more verifiable paper
ballots than ever before these are
ballots that you can go back to and
audit and recount 95 of all voters in
the United States cast ballots on paper
in 2020 the most ever it was only about
75 percent in 2016. every Battleground
state had paper ballots and in all of
those States the ballots were audited we
confirmed that the machines that counted
the ballots did so accurately we had
more pre-election litigation than ever
before clarifying the rules every
candidate every campaign knew what the
rules were on Election Day they might
not have liked them all both sides liked
some and didn't like some but they knew
what the rules were and then
post-election of course we famously had
more litigation than ever before 60
courts looked at the evidence confirmed
that the results were accurate even
Trump appointed judges did that and so
the result was a great Triumph of
American democracy the highest turnout
we'd ever seen 20 million more voters
than we've ever seen in any election
managed during a global pandemic all
verified and when we say yes Triumph of
democracy we don't mean you have to be
satisfied with the result
lots of people are unhappy that
President Biden won fine some people
missed the Trump presidency fine but
disenthrall yourself from the idea
that because you're unhappy that
entitles you or gives you license
to condemn something that was actually
an example of American cooperation
collaboration Innovation and a positive
result for the furtherance of our
Democratic experiment you imagine a
January 2023 as going very very badly if
you could sketch briefly that very bad
outcome and what we can do to prevent so
to make it clear to everyone this is
speculative fiction it's a non-fiction
book that opens with a chapter of
speculative fiction we're imagining
something that could happen
all right Texas changed its laws after
2020 making already restrictive laws
even more restrictive and there are
concerns and they manifest themselves in
the March primary there that voters of
color might have more difficulty
complying with those so we paint a
scenario where also under Texas law you
can open carry and poll observers
election Watchers have been given more
powers to move around and contest things
so there's an argument and the argument
escalates and nobody knows how or why
but a gunshot goes off and a voter dies
and Democrats looking at this nationally
say oh my God this is now a death in a
polling place
and this looks like an assault on
Democracy that is now riddled with blood
on the floor literally in a voting
Precinct
and they say look these tensions are so
intense we've reached our breaking point
in terms of Tolerance and the Speaker of
the House in this speculative fiction
story we say doesn't seat the entire
Texas delegation Republicans and
Democrats as a protest over what's going
on in Texas and because it's a close
election that delegation
decides who controls the house so now
who controls the House of
Representatives is up for grabs and so
we have to save the country the big lie
is the era the big truth is the book
it'll be good conversation at
Thanksgiving on sale now we'll be right
back